Roy Williams the only coach all time
with at least 400 wins at two different
schools 418 wins at Kansas and 466 at
North Carolina in fact no coaches even
one 300 games at two different Division
one schools coach joins us this morning
coach how are you well I've got some
news for you Dan
yeah Tom Brady's coming back to North
Carolina to be reinvent himself to be in
North Carolina basketball player he saw
a game last week and he it and he said
he could help you could help between and
Jimmy Kimmel standing up on the scores
table and his receiver saying he's
coming back Tom told me I am coming back
as a college basketball player
I appreciate that coach thank you you
heard it first yeah I did I don't know
if I'll hear in second but I did hear at
first there would football team do you
phone you know I followed the Panthers a
little bit because I love McCaffrey Ron
Rivera's was always so great to us
mr. Richardson I knew him when I was an
assistant but I really don't follow a
lot of teams as much as I do
coaches or individuals but I'll throw
you a curveball
my favorite NFL team of all time is the
Tennessee Titans because they started as
a Houston Oilers and had George Blanda
and Billy Cannon and Charlie tour and
Charlie Hennessey I mean add all those
guys and it's the first pro football
game I ever saw on TV and so I've been a
Houston Oilers or al Campbell fan ever
since do you play football in high
school no quit in the eighth grade
because those guys just get bigger and I
wasn't getting any bigger a way to cool
hundred pounds as a night grader in high
school but after the eighth grade those
guys just kept getting bigger and bigger
and I didn't how would you sum up if
somebody didn't see your team play this
year how would you sum up maybe in one
sentence this season so far
that I should have continued coaching
football given I did coach high school
football for four years as an assistant
so that's what they would save what
starting this year is that I should have
found another vocation but do you start
to doubt yourself well I think Danny I
think it I've always doubted my
self every game after the game I said
god I should have done this I should
have done that and I don't know if I can
say doubted myself but I've always
questioned myself and I think probably
questioned yourself during years like
this more than you ever do and so it's a
reason when we do have great years I
truly try to spend some time to go back
and look and make sure that I look and
study things a great deal even we have
great years much less what we've what
we've been going through this year I
have to be honest I was worried about
you a little bit this year and this
wasn't health-related but just from afar
I was like you know I don't know if
you're enjoying yourself and you know
there's a challenge there every year for
you for every coach but I don't know
this it got to you a lot more than I
thought it would well I think I'm lucky
because we haven't had I've never gone
through anything like this but so I've
been so so lucky but I do take it
personally and I do take it to home with
me I do wake up in the middle of the
night and and and I haven't done as good
a job with this team I think that the
way I evaluate my coaching is did I get
the team to play to their potential did
I get every individual to play to their
potential and and be able to make good
decisions under adversity and to come
through and their adversity and and I
haven't gotten this team to to do as
well you know it's it's a kind of thing
that it still bothers me I didn't sleep
very well last night so I don't know
that I'll start sleeping any better
until we start winning more but we've
we've won three in a row and that that
makes it better but I've just never gone
through this and it's been hard it
really has and but I'd really sit back a
lot of times to think that other people
really really have some problems and my
problems not trying to trying to figure
out how to get one stop we've lost six
games this year that if we had gotten
one defensive stop we could have been to
six no instead we got zero and so we
were over in six and those games yeah
and then that would give you 19 wins on
the season and you know you wouldn't be
in the position where you are where
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to win out to make the tournament I'm
guessing that would be yep that's what
would think Kemba Walker style and you
know he's delay their team not just
Kimball but Kimball was sensational but
they won their last five to get in the
tournament and won all six games in the
NC double-a tournament so it can be done
it's it's not easy to say the least but
I'll give you the difference in Roy
Webb's and coach Dean Smith there's
about a million of them a million miles
but my first year as an assistant coach
here in North Carolina
we won five games where the other team
had the last shot to win the game and
missed all five so we were five and O
that year this year we row at six so I
told coach Smith that's really good
coaching and we had a little bit of a
chuckle about it a couple of years after
that but there's no chuckling going on
in Roy bill right now who did you hear
from after you dropped the f-bomb after
the game against North Carolina or out
of Notre Dame you know almost no one it
really was one one a fellow coach said
I'm glad you're normal laughed but I
didn't laughter time it's something I
shouldn't have done and it's just it
just came out the question sort of
bothered me and and I let that get to me
and it was something I'm not proud of
but you know I'm not proud of a lot of
things of Doug's just haven't done it in
the front of with microphones in front
of me
he's Roy Williams North Carolina head
coach got Duke coming up on Saturday
three-time national champ
you said you bring your losses home with
you mm-hmm
there's no rule where you know your wife
said or you know somebody says hey don't
bring that home or leave it at the door
you know you know it's crazy when we win
I tell the guys he enjoyed till midnight
and then was missed or moving ahead and
the losses just they stick with me Dan
and in fact the night before I left
North Carolina to go to Kansas as the
head coach we had dinner at coach
Smith's house and he said his biggest
worry about me is how hard I took the
losses as an assistant and he gets a
million times worse as the head coach
and he low-balled it it's a lot worse
than that but
it is you know when I was in high school
coach and I thought there were two bad
things about coaching having to cut
players and losing and so in college
it's only one you know it's just the
losing but I do I sit back and try to
tell myself how lucky I am and I am and
good gracious god knows them but the
luckiest guy you can possibly be but the
losses do go home with me and it's it's
hard but it's hard on every coach and
it's well my wife says nobody takes it
as hard as I do and but she has to live
through it but thankfully this summer
will be 47 years so she's put up with a
lot she just goes to bed and closes the
door locks me outside or whatever she
feels like doing
what's the scouting report on Duke great
team great coach big inside threat with
Vernon carry what Gard trade Jones who's
just one of the best leaders in college
basketball who was a really good player
last year this turned into a great
player this year some talented freshman
like stea kasia stanley jumps out of the
gym and what you have to do in our
opinion my opinion Roy Williams you have
to attack you have to score because
they're going score so you better keep
scoring if you have a scoring drought in
that game it's you go home with a sad
look on your face
surprised at Zion success in the NBA
no no no I think I saw him in high
school
more than any other head coach over a
two-year period I was down there like 13
times and just thought he was the most
amazing specimen I'd ever seen why would
you lose him yeah how does he lose him I
wish I could find out if I knew that I
would have lost it would have change but
no Duke did a great job but I tell you
what he was some people that did some of
the most amazing things in high school
that I've ever seen and yet I've always
worried about his knees and his ankles
is his lower body because the guy jumps
so high with that amount of weight that
there's a collision every time he comes
down
and but I just think he's he's got this
air about him that people enjoy him
people like him
he's very gregarious personality and and
jumps higher and plays harder and runs
faster than just about anybody that's
ever played the game at that size and
you know he's he's got to stand the test
of time in the NBA but truly one of the
greatest high school players and college
players that I've ever seen really great
to talk to you and I hope you have fun
the rest of this season and I'm sure
that you'll bounce back next season but
well we're gonna try to try to win as
many as we can and then go see if I can
make a birdie for a couple of weeks and
then we'll start worried about next year
we've got a good group coming in and
hopefully I'll do a better job coaching
them Dan Thank You coach good to talk to
you good to talk to you partner that's
Roy Williams